well let's talk about the next bit of uh
drama that's erupting across the
internet check this out from timcast.com
Sydney Watson sues Blaze TV over alleged
abuse by Elijah Shafer wow this is so
crazy okay look for those that aren't
familiar data show on Blaze called uh
you are here right yeah you are here
um relatively short-lived I think the
blaze deleted all of the content and
changed the channel into Prime Time with
Alex Stein is that what happened yes
because that's what I saw I just want to
make sure I'm gonna write
okay that's a bad idea for any reason
like that's that's you know people who
subscribe to watch Elijah and Sydney
aren't they're gonna unsubscribe like
crazy and then you've got a weird
algorithmic thing but uh but I
understand why they do that you don't
want to just nuke a channel but in this
instance we have more alt media uh
conflict in fighting this story it says
uh from timcast.com former Blaze TV
personality and YouTuber Sydney Watson
is suing the outlet for retaliation and
wrongful termination along with
religious and sex discrimination for
alleged abuse by fellow former Blaze
personality Elijah Shafer that's crazy
because I thought they were friends but
I know that she quit I know the show
fell apart
so I'll also add I'm not sure that um
Elijah has put out a statement or
anything so what you're getting are
accusations yeah and again I'm not
saying Sydney's wrong I'm just saying we
I don't know what the full picture is
they say Watson claims she signed with
the Blaze TV because the company
reportedly represented itself as an
incubator of talent citing previous
success with past personalities Dana
lash and Tommy Lauren Tommy Lauren the
former personality also claimed the
Outlet's moral values played a role in
their decision to sign with Blaze TV
Watson claimed Schaefer engaged in
misogyny and acted in a grossly sexual
nature and reportedly drank on set
though Blaze TV reportedly catered to
the man's tantrums and misbehavior of
Schaefer according to the complaint
citing Schaefer as the star and primary
asset of the outlet
he appeared to enjoy the intimidation
factor that his physical size gave him
with respect to Miss Watson rides
Watson's complaint the choice of guests
compounded Miss Watson's growing
discomfort with the anti-female tone of
the show and off-air interactions Watson
cited the December 3rd appearance of
controversial political commentator Nick
Fuentes claiming he was grossly
misogynistic and Schaefer appeared to
condone the behavior it was at this time
at about this time the environment of
the production began to become notably
more hostile not merely to Miss Watson
but to many of the women at the Belize
that's very interesting Watson further
cited a hostile interaction during a
December 2021 episode in which guest
Jack Murphy berated Watson regarding the
content of a viewer's Super Chat the
former Blaze DB personality further
accused her co-host of unilaterally
booking guests with particularly
contemptible and sexist opinions towards
women
the complaint also claimed audience
members were encouraged by Mr Schaefer
Schaefer's conduct and attacked Miss
Watson so often so intensely that other
guests denoted it and were put off the
suit cites super chats containing
grossly sexist and anti-jewish sentiment
which Miss Watson claimed was cultivated
by Schaefer
okay yeah I don't know what do you guys
think I've been on the show a couple
times I was on with Alex one time Alex
Jones and I was also on as a standalone
guest the one time that I was on as a
standalone guest uh Elijah got
significant like he got real drunk wow
he got drunk enough where I wasn't going
out after the show to hang out I went
back to my hotel room in in the studio
he got drunk yep yep and uh the when I
was on with Alex he wasn't I don't
recall him being significantly drunk but
uh but the one time that I was on you
know it was awkward and weird
um but you know he was nice but you can
tell that he had been drinking so maybe
and I didn't see him behave in a in a in
an inappropriate way when I was there
um but I know how booze is I mean
there's a reason I don't drink anymore
the one thing I did hear was that Sydney
would often raid super chats that
contain dog whistles or whatever people
were saying and she wouldn't know she
would be like hey read the Super Chat
and she would read I think that's one of
the complaints she had that she'd get
goaded into reading these offensive and
was there that they read every
single Super Chat I I didn't I didn't
watch the show I think at first it was
when it was still growing but yeah they
would have super chats there's like a
new viral clip it's not of Sydney Watson
but it's basically these two girls and
one girl's like happy birthday too and
it's like a word that says the N word
but they didn't realize until after so
they would do that to Sydney a lot and I
think with Sydney her her failure on
that was the second you show that it
bothers you people are gonna keep going
that's like as someone has like a troll
like I noticed if I say something that
bothers someone I keep don't if someone
tells me not to do something I do it so
like that's just the way she handled it
incorrectly and just I feel like
Elijah's audience just did not mesh with
her I never thought that they were a
good mixture in general because she's
pretty feminist especially for the right
in my view like she's Sydney is yeah I
mean
yeah she probably would not like the
stuff I post I mean I kind of feel like
I I don't I don't look Elijah Shafer
hasn't come out and issued a statement
done this but Sydney seems to be a more
level-headed person when it comes to
issues of feminism she she calls out the
BS yeah so I kind of feel like if she's
coming out and being like hey this is
what happened granted this is like I've
not heard what she's said about it
probably she won't because you don't
speak when you're in a lawsuit
but I'm kind of like she's credible on
this stuff if she's coming out and
saying hey these are things that were
bad like I would I'd take it seriously I
don't want to throw Elijah under the
basket I don't know yeah but I don't see
I don't see Sydney lying about something
when she's level-headed about it it's so
hard to weigh in on this because we're
obviously not there we don't know she
seems great she's talented uh I was
really grateful Elijah had me on after I
went to the opening statements for
January 6 and he had me on talk my
article super professional it was a good
experience but I am not in the room with
either one of them every day right I
don't know Sydney I don't know Elisha
all that well and it is hard to see
these things hashed out in a public
forum not that they shouldn't be but
because people are so quick to weigh in
on these things that you actually have
very limited experience about if she was
treated badly that's terrible uh and I
hope there is something to do like
something happens from it but also like
I feel like I have to be really careful
and say like I I don't know what's going
on are we in a simulation guys be honest
with me is this a Truman Show are you
guys Punk me or something because we had
crowd on The Daily wire from December
into January we have project Veritas and
O'Keefe obviously we we got and brought
in some drama and that's why this is
exactly what I'm like
this this stuff freaks me out now you've
got Blaze undergoing its own version how
is all of this happening at the same
time because the uh midterms haven't
really kicked off or the uh the
elections haven't yeah primaries haven't
kicked off yet that's why I don't I
don't know I mean I know drama happens
all the time but to this degree at this
level and according to the independent
Outlet kind of like one by one by one
it's designated like you said to him but
I was joking but this is exactly why I
was like I don't want to fight I don't
want to fight look like I'll I'll eat
crawl do whatever I'm scared that this
stuff is just bad for what may be like
the last Bastion of Hope in a chaotic
world it's not just about wokeness it's
not just about Democrats or whatever
it's about the fires of chaos and the
struggle of order to maintain it's like
it feels like we're the last City with
our walls fortifying us and every day
the fires and the zombies are trying to
break in and we're trying to reclaim you
know this territory if we're fighting
inside over politics it's just
um full disclosure I've been very
friendly with Elijah in the past and
I've been friendly with Sydney in the
past too I think the most Troublesome
part of this is that unfortunately this
isn't Elijah's only trouble that
happened at the blaze I think he got
fired for inappropriate behavior towards
another co-worker in the past and I
think the a bigger Trend here not just
with Elijah but with a lot of
influencers is failing to live up to the
values that they perpetuate or claim to
perpetuate so if you're claiming that
you're a family man and you know you
believe that males should protect
females and you know that sort of
ideology and then you don't exhibit any
of those characteristics on the show and
you're married and behave in a different
way you know at your company then uh I
think a bigger issue here is again
people failing to live up to their
values or the values that they're claim
and you guys could read them between the
lines here because I'm not giving a lot
of details but I think this isn't only
an issue with Elijah many people fail to
live up to the values they espouse
um and I just kind of wanted to get that
out there because that is you know yeah
that's that's why that's why like even
though like this is a a fairly
conservative uh
orbit uh show a lot of social
conservatives and stuff like that that's
why I'm very open and clear that I am a
totally degenerate like I don't want
people thinking that I'm gonna say oh
hey you know or that I'm gonna be saying
that I'm some kind of social
conservative or that you know uh you
know someone be like oh Phil
this girl that Phil hooked up with blah
blah blah or whatever like the the there
is no there is no Heirs of of putting on
like oh I'm some kind of you're not
saying you're a Trad man while you're
yeah I'm saying you don't drink and then
drink and then you know you know you
have a wife and then behave in ways that
people with wives shouldn't behave so
like you're not putting on a Persona
that's not true aren't you a rock star
you're you're exactly you know I mean
you know you doing things is different
than people who claimed to be too many
larpers yeah but yeah but the thing is
they're yeah but they're just like like
you said it's too many people that
aren't aren't living up to the values
that they despise like there's very very
rarely is anyone gonna be able to say oh
Phil you're supporting this big
government idea blah blah blah you know
I'm fairly consistent with my political
ideology but when it comes to you know
when it comes to social conservative
things I'm not a social conservative so
and this is oftentimes too people will
gay keep others and say you're not
enough of this you're not doing enough
of this when in reality if they looked
in the mirror they aren't actually
exemplifying any of the qualities that
they perpetuate right do you think
anything sorry just real quick
um obviously we know a lot of people
involved in this yeah so I until I get
uh confirmation that I'm allowed to
share I've got people right now blowing
up my phone over this stuff uh I'll just
say right now what I'm hearing from
multiple people is disputed like
the the conflict between the two is sure
disputed basically like I'll leave it at
that because I need I need to after the
show talk to them and say hey can we get
this on record and stuff like that but
uh but this wasn't the reason Elijah was
originally fired from the blazes I
understand
um it was another situation um an
incident with him and Sarah Gonzalez oh
that's right person who did work at the
blaze so that that's why I mentioned
that other thing and that it's part of a
more Grand people perpetuating
um
positions of themselves that isn't
aren't necessary I'm friendly with Sid
as well like I don't I don't want to
like I I personally I like we have a
a rapport and uh I she's not the kind of
person that makes stuff up so from my
perspective you know well I think
clearly people have a hunger for this
political drama so I think what we
should do is have a Jersey Shore style
political reality TV show house so that
way we can get our drama fixed and every
every one of the alternative media
companies have to send one person yeah
there's our drama because I think that's
our best bet you'll be desperately
trying to make everyone get along but
naively like not understanding the
political conflict like we'll get
leftists and right Wingers we'll be like
gosh you you've got to work together on
this and they'll be like he's a fascist
she's a Kami this is a great idea right
this is the game show right that's a
missing piece at the very least it'd be
a hilarious sitcom oh yeah yeah so viral
so viral I'm like re-watching Jersey
Shore right now and they filmed that
when it was okay to be not woke and
they're super offensive and I'm just
thinking wow imagine we just put like a
bunch of the biggest political
influencers all in one house and record
it amazing are they doing a reunion
jersey shirts they've been doing it I'm
launching it they do like a family
vacation
they can never stop do you think that
some of these issues come up especially
in Social conservative circles because
people misunderstand what being
traditional means what being
traditionally masculine means but what
being feminine means do you think that
there's any any times a
misinterpretation of what those values
are that gets people into trouble I
think there might be a misinterpretation
of what is traditionally masculine and
what is a positive masculine uh what is
positive masculine behavior and I think
that that is because of the way that
masculine men have been portrayed for
the past 30 years or so I don't think
that it's a misunderstanding of what
like traditional is I think that it's
just
dude to be horny like yeah and and like
booze lowers inhibitions and all the
things that all of the vices that are
you know vices that lead people astray
from you know whatever kind of
puritanical ideas they have you know I
think that that's a very normal
thing that happens not something that we
should you know that you should be happy
about but it's something that's very
normal and I I don't think Scandal is
new scan you know Scandal and that kind
of behavior goes as far back as there's
been human beings yeah I I it makes me
think of I've known some people who
describe themselves as alpha males who
you see them conduct themselves and what
their what they think seem to believe is
uh being a strong man is actually being
very domineering and being sort of it's
it's like this misinterpretation you
don't know if because maybe they've been
fed this one narrative so long there's
an overcompensation or if they actually
don't if they can't kind of evaluate how
they are conducting themselves you know
so like someone like Andrew Tate is
definitely not like he's definitely a
masculine dude but I don't think that
he's the kind of dude that you should
emulate if you are if you are looking to
have a traditional life you know if
that's your deal you know I don't think
that Andrew Tates the guy you should try
to be at all you know I feel like we're
living in a golden age of being a fraud
because it's easier to lie about your
resume more than ever it goes beyond
people that we're talking about now it's
like liver King guy was you know was
selling people a bill of goods that was
anybody that believes liver King wasn't
doing steroids I have a bridge in
Brooklyn that is up for sale give me DM
me my DMs are open I will sell you that
but sadly a lot of young men believe him
but I I've got a I gotta I don't know
enough about Andrew Tate but um I feel
like there is a matrix attack against
him to smear him I'm actually only half
kidding when I say that because I've the
clips I've seen of him
not the ones that people spread around
to Samira that may be bad he may have
said those bad things but I've heard
good things from him yeah I've heard
things that are and and the response I
hear from people is like oh well you
know actually when Eliza blue was on she
was like he's not saying anything new or
unique that no one else has I'm like
yeah but he's like a championship
kickboxer who's coming out and telling
guys to work hard be successful stop
don't give up start working out eat
right and I'm like that's pretty good
the fact that a guy can generate a
massive following and make a ton of
money because he's convinced a bunch of
a bunch of young men to start doing
push-ups and exercise is good as for the
other stuff I can only say we talked
about on this show two of the women that
they claim were victims came out said
they weren't and the judge ruled they
were it's like if you can have witnesses
come out and actually defend you because
a court says you're not allowed to so
I'll put it this way they've not charged
the Tates with a crime
they arrested them with no charges and
I'm like so everyone's saying like this
is a matrix attack against the Tate
brothers and we're like well I don't
know I've seen these videos and then
it's like oh by the way they never
actually charged them they just locked
them up because that's what they do in
Romania I guess and then it's like oh
okay now I've got questions about this
then when the witnesses came out and
said they weren't victims and then the
judge said nah you're brainwashed and
people went well sometimes people are
brainwashed I'm like I don't care a
woman has agency if she says I am fine
with this there's no victim yeah but
they still lock the guy up so I'm not
trying to come out with the full throw
defense Avenger kicks I don't know a lot
of what he said all I know is that
doesn't make sense and all I know is the
messages that I've heard he had one
where he said rocket ship to the Moon
doesn't stop halfway to take a break it
keeps going and it keeps working and I'm
like
I mean I like that I don't know about
the rest of it I don't follow the guy
you know what I mean I mean you to To Be
A Champion fighter you do have to have a
work ethic that that is is at least
a step or two beyond the average person
and he came from nothing because I used
to watch a lot of clips of him in
interviews because I I like the most
offensive annoying people on the
internet so naturally I gravitated
towards him shocking I know I wanted to
like him like when I first like the
first time that I ever saw him was the
Star Wars keep yours there's this this
thing he's like I never saw Star Wars
I'm a millionaire I've never seen Star
Wars either which that was the first
time I was fun I was like you know okay
I get it it got attention and stuff and
and I wanted to be like all right this
guy is you know she seems kind of over
the top but maybe he's you know now I
like him more because I've never seen
Star Wars either but my point is is he
actually did come from nothing he's
talked about how whenever it was him and
or his brother's birthday they would go
to KFC because they're that poor they
would go to KFC and go pick up the
chicken that are in leftover buckets
that were on tables and now every time
for their birthdays even though they're
rich now even though they're locked up
right now but when they're rich they
still go to KFC because it's like
nostalgic so he came from nothing I know
his father was like a really world-class
chess player and he could never beat his
dad but the one thing he could do is
fight so I think it's a really cool
story I like Rags to Riches stories all
the time I've become so cynical with all
these influencers and it seems like
everybody's a fraud now I'm not saying
he is but it also feel like he came out
of nowhere it almost seemed like it felt
like he was being pushed if you will I
don't have any this is reckless
speculation right now but it did feel as
though he kept getting shoved in your
face and not being super controversial
and then he converted to Islam well he
was he was on a TV show in the UK first
he was like big brother or something
like that so he had he had a little bit
of a a bassist to start from
um and then and that was after sports
right he did the sports retired did Big
Brother yeah so I mean he had some kind
of you know base to start with but and
again like I said I wanted to like him
or I want I want I hope that it's you
know I hope that he didn't actually do
anything wrong and that he's you know
that he's he was legit but uh I don't
know that I believe it yeah either I
don't know that I I haven't seen enough
evidence either way to have a strong
opinion the videos and clips that I've
seen are meaningless to me upon finding
out they've not charged them with any
crimes that's that I didn't know that
either so I've I've had enough fake
videos put out about me I've been
complaining about it non-stop like I'm
not gonna buy it yeah show me the
charger send the investigation the media
puts out all this stuff they attack the
guy yeah and I think it's funny that he
calls it a matrix attack and then people
laugh at the idea because it's like what
are you talking about Matrix attack and
then it's like oh by the way they accept
someone super chatted they extended his
his lot the lock up yeah despite no
criminal charges
that apparently that's how Romania
operates they arrest you and then
investigate well that kind of reminds me
of when O'Keefe back to O'Keefe was
arrested in his apartment in New York
City or New York one time and he I
remember him telling me that they there
was no charges they didn't charge with
anything but they took his phone so they
stole his private property and didn't
give it back to him without a charge I
mean I mean this is happening in America
too the government sucks like TP USA has
big governments better what is it the
government sucks big government sucks
sorry it's been a long time and
socialism sucks socialism sucks like
like you suck like check true like our
vice president who sucks the most but
but if if you're talking about
government sucking let's um let's
literalize it it sucks money from your
pocket and the bigger it is the more it
sucks yeah so it definitely sucks that's
so true
but anyway yeah I don't know we got into
the subject of of Andrew Tate I think
outside of him and all this stuff is
going on there's a reason why people
like him become so big
yo there are a bunch of men who are
growing up they feel masculinity within
them
and these are normal things that are
good yep we're not talking about
whatever the toxic masculine is supposed
to be it's a guy being like I want to
you know go to the gym and I want to
work out and they're constantly being
told it's wrong
I think for a lot of young men who are I
should just say young men a lot of men
that are overweight or out of shape and
eating bad they want to be encouraged to
feel good they want a strong leader to
encourage them and and you know be that
Father Figure or that that Commander so
you're seeing people it's funny Jordan
Peterson right Jordan Peterson's no
fighter I mean politically he's a
fighter I mean that that whole c-16 bill
in Canada that dude went to war with us
but he's also kind of a frail
intellectual not to try to be mean he's
expecting him in a kickboxing ring no
he's a skinny guy he says clean your
room gosh darn it and then Andrew Tate
is this super ripped kickboxer who's
saying clean your room dude like yelling
at you we like dudes are yearning for
someone to just tell them it's okay to
be yourself yeah dude exactly that is I
think that you are dead on with that the
the I think that the fact that there has
been such an influence
um by the left and feminism is a
left-leaning ideology I think
um for since the 90s it's been Al Bundy
is the is the the father and everything
every it's it's some kind of half
that's lucky to be in a marriage with
the smart wife that saves him from his
own stupidity all the time and it's
either that or it's like Arnold
Schwarzenegger and even even like the
the The Rock was the kind of the guy but
even he's not Red Foreman and that 70
show people loved him as yeah all the
time yeah and it's it's because it's
Mass masculine like positive masculine
Role Models have been almost entirely
removed from society I mean look at Sam
Smith the pictures that he just put out
today he looked like a ham he literally
looked like a ham and this is what they
put on stage this is what they celebrate
and look I'm I'm fairly libertarian Sam
do your thing bro I got no issues he's
in bondage gear or whatever that's his
thing but this is what they're
encouraging and what I think we're
seeing now is you've got Young man this
let's go back in time remember how they
were talking about putting kids on 80 uh
ADHD medication Adderall Ritalin and
then you see like these the Trope of the
kid like fidgeting in class and they're
like stop stop fidgeting
it's because these young young boys
mostly young boys have energy and they
want to use it they want to run they
want to jump they want to exercise they
want to that's what they do and what
they were doing is they were effectively
feminizing because young women that sit
still and are not as fidgety and you
know crazy and aggressive so they're
effect they're sort of trying to train
out this Natural Energy which is a good
thing you know guys grow into it they
focus it and they utilize that for
you know lifting steel beams and doing
construction or playing sports or
whatever but they're trying they're
trying to lock these kids up and they
said oh these kids don't want to stop
fidgeting give them drugs people are
trying to break out of this cage and for
some reason there is a strong effort to
promote the idea that they should be in
the cage institutions find it easier to
manipulate submissive people right I'm
not saying women are just
naturally all submissive they should be
but submission is a female trait and it
works really well in a strong
partnership right I mean yeah no
seriously seriously the worst thing
that's ever happened to this country
don't even get me started so true but
all the men are like women you can vote
and the women in the room were like no
yeah why don't you see I said what's
watching the show I'll keep the right to
vote as long as you guys keep putting
out Fast and Furious movies yes other
than that that's where I question your
judgment but no I think that women the
word submission has been made to see
evil and at times being submitting to uh
big government to Authority can be bad
but for women it's more about a role in
Partnership and I think that for public
schools let's say with boys you know if
you if you give a young girl a Direction
go to your desk and sit down and be
quiet maybe she'll do it because maybe
that's her energy and that's what comes
with being female and if a little boy is
like but I want to do that there
whatever like it's not a bad thing
they're just different right but it
becomes easier to which kid do you want
your class then if you're the teacher
the one who's going to listen to your
rules you're not willing to change your
structure to the needs of the students
you want them to conform to what you
need because that's what school is
though sorry yeah yeah I'm curious
though with like people like Sam Smith
and that's the idea they're pushing
forward or the Gillette commercial where
it's like toxic masculinity and that
commercial it was like a guy saw a woman
you want to talk to her and then other
guy's like don't don't do it bro yeah
like the guy goes ooh and he sees the
girl walk by it's like how are you
supposed to meet women just don't like
you know that's the message given to
young guys like I mean young dudes that
are like not like the top 10 percent of
dudes or whatever they got it rough they
got it real rough have you seen these
there's they're these old interviews
with incels it's like a normal looking
guy but he's convinced something's wrong
with him or he's ugly he's not a chat or
whatever and it's just like bro you just
need to go out but when the TV says your
whole life guys shouldn't talk to women
when they do that video 10 hours of
walking through New York as a woman and
they're complaining that someone said
morning it's like a guy and he's like
how do you how do you do and they're
like oh well I never or the or the tick
tock videos where guys try to go up and
help you know the we were talking about
it the other night that the gym Tick
Tock videos or uh you know there was a
Media Matters girl was catfishing dudes
on Swipe right these people would never
last on The Truman Show basic
friendliness is bad yeah what do you
think of the way we're molding modern
day masculinity and femininity oh
starting to get me started I mean
they're trying to make men women and
women men because then they're going to
be naturally unhappy because they're
walking outside of their roll and then
they're going to be way more easily
dominated and submit to the government
that's what they want they want to
dismantle the American family they want
to dismantle masculinity and women want
to become men like I was just on a
jubilee Middle Ground Middle Ground
panel as an anti-feminist and I mean
literally they the feminists are so
brainwashed against men that one of the
girls the one of the feminists I was
saying well what about strong men that
protect you from bad men because if
you're a girl walking home alone
wouldn't you rather have a good man with
you to protect you and she and this girl
goes well what about now the good man
gets to just get praised because he's
good but who is he being compared to bad
men so it's like now they're getting mad
at Good Men protecting you it's hard for
me even to articulate because it
literally makes zero sense or you could
have a gun or you have a gun which they
want to get rid of too I know that's the
craziest thing we have both right you
have a strong good man and a gun like
right this is that limit these things
and then you you you defend yourselves
from criminals and it's like a family
thing like you're protecting each other
you know yeah crazy the family unit
might be good well think about it this
way you got a big strong man and his
wife they're both armed and then a
criminal appears the guy says I don't
want to use lethal Force but struggles
to stop the guy and the woman says I can
now protect you too I think everybody
should have guns that's just me men or
women are supposed to be in Partnership
and they have traits to balance each
other I don't know how you feel about
that oh no absolutely absolutely I'm
married recently married within the last
year thank you thank you and I used to
I've always been anti-feminist never
been on the left or a feminist but I
used to pretty much live kind of like I
just want to do my career and I just
wanna I don't wanna ever have kids I
don't really want to get married I'm
very I um I was gonna say isolationist
I'm very introverted I like to be by
myself but I've never been happier than
I've been now actually being a wife and
like cooking my husband dinner and just
he comes first and serving that and like
now I do want kids and I'm it's it's
great and I've never would have thought
I wanted that and I've never been
happier before in my life and that
message needs to be told to more girls
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time